habe ich gesagt dass ich günstigere
Kalender auspacke das war gelogen eine
habe ich noch ein habe ich noch ich habe
noch einen teuren Kalender hier den muss
ich auch noch mal auspacken es tut mir
leid ich weiß nur nicht was ich mit
diesem Kalender gemacht habe oder ob er
so angekommen ist diese roten Flecken J
ich habe den richtig dreckig gemacht
aber das war ich nicht immer erstmal von
sich selbst wegschieben die schultld
Lebensweisheit Nummer ein heute packen
wir
den Laurent Adventskalender aus ich bin
eine kleine luxusmaus wann habe ich denn
sonst mal einen Grund so teure Produkte
in der Hand zu haben diesen
Adventskalender bekommt man für
35 € 345
€ das ist aber gegen den Swarowski
Kalender und Dior kalalender ein
richtiges Schnäppchen ist aber glaube
ich auch ein bisschen günstiger das ist
fashionhaus ah ja ein Fashion houseus
natürlich das wusste ich ist nicht so
bekannt wie Dior aber dieses Teil kostet
345 € und wir wollen mal rausfinden ob
sich das lohnt kennen wir die Antwort
schon vielleicht packen wir trotzdem aus
na sicher ich habe aufgehört mein
Gesicht zu pudern ich glänze vielleicht
wie eine Schweineschwarte aber ich habe
so viel Puder in den letzten Tagen
benutzt durch dieses ganze
Adventskalender drehen dass ich so
ausgetrocknete Augenpartien
hatte und das kam von so einem
koreanischen Puder okay also wir sind
ganz schick gemacht ich sehe aus wie
eine Mitarbeiterin bei y Laurent und
jetzt packen wir den Kalender aus und
wir machen ihn
auf wow jetzt mal ohne Witz das ist ein
richtig hochwertiges Papier wenn ich im
Bastelladen dieses Papier holen wollen
würde Seidenpapier ja sowas in der Art
ne so ein wachsseidenpapier das alleine
kostet schon 50 Cent haben wir doch
unser Geld gleich wieder zurück erste
Eindruck es wirkt ein bisschen wie die
billigere Version von dem Dior
Adventskalender ihr könnt jetzt
vielleicht nicht so erkennen aber so vom
vom Feeling und so da merkt man nur noch
die 250 € Unterschied ah ja und einmal
aufgemacht kriegt man ihn nicht noch mal
zu weil der so nervige Teile hier hat na
ja der wirkt der wirkt der wirkt ein
bisschen ich will es nicht sagen er
wirkt aber für 345 € wirkt ein bisschen
billig so dann machen wir mal
Türchen aber man packt hier auch ein
kleines Geschenk aus aber hier steht
nicht das Logo drauf ne das Papier bei
Dior war schon heftig in Türchen Nummer
ein ich weiß dass sie auch bekannt sind
für ihre Lippenstifte oder oh war nur
abwärter Zuhörer tolle Farbe wow auch
wieder eine Farbe für mich aber auch der
Lippen ich meine natürlich das muss
nicht wie Dior wirken aber das wirkt
nicht mal wie es ist so ja wenn ich die
Marke nicht kenne würde dann wäre das
für mich halt ein ganz stink normaler
Lippenstift na mal gucken die Qualität
ist bestimmt überragend oh mein Gott die
Farbe finde ich wunderschön aber das ist
so stark perfüiert es riecht als ob ich
perfüm aufgetragen habe und das ist halt
bei Lippenstift den ich direkt am Mund
habe sehr nervig weil das direkt unter
der Nase ist wenn ich den bei jemandem
ausprobieren würde würde ich ihn mir
nicht Nachkauf ollen übelst perfüiert
Nummer 2ch der Kalender das ist es ist
noch mal ein riesen Unterschied zwischen
345 und 600 € aber wenn ich 345 € für
Make-up Beauty Kalender bezahle 345
€ wei nicht diger Türchen Nummer Z ist
das ein Stift ich sag's euch selbst das
Papier wirkt nicht so toll oh es ist ein
Kajal nee ganz ehrlich ich gebe den an
euch ich habe so viele Kajalstifte und
wenn ich den jetzt einmal benutze der
wahrscheinlich wie ein ganz normaler
kajarchift einfach funktionieren wird
verschwendet der kommt in die
verlosungsbox diese Woche habt ihr die
Chance die ganzen Sachen aus den
Adventskalendern zu gewinnen denn ich
werde eigene Adventskalender packen und
sie an Euch verlosen mit all dem Inhalt
aus den Kalendern oh scheiße ihr dürft
meine Hose nicht
sehen dafür müsst ihr mir einfach nur
auf Instagram folgen und dann bekommt
ihr mit wann die Verlosung startet und
was ihr tun müsst und ich werden dieses
Jahr diese Kalender packen wir haben das
jetzt auch schon die letzten Jahre
gemacht und dieses Jahr wollen wir sie
halt wirklich selber basteln und ich bin
mal gespannt wie viele Kalender wir
rauskriegen also ich glaube so 10 15
Stück werden es schon sein und ich bin
mal gespannt ze ja ungefähr 240 Sachen
müssen wir verpacken das wird Spaß
machen Nummer 3 uh hier ist sehr viel
nee ah eine kleine miniprobe black Opium
uh cute das ist ja ein schickes Parfüm
oh ja kriegt ungefähr wieder Lippenstift
ein sehr Erwachsener Duft für abends
würde ich sagen ach Mensch der
Lippenstift ist ja der wird ein ja
hinterher geworfen einer in
Originalgröße kostet
3349 30 ml von diesem Parfüm Kosten 4568
irgendwie fühle ich diese Marke nicht
ich bin mal noch gespannt aber ich habe
jetzt gerade nicht das Gefühl so uh ich
habe so tolle Produkte Nummer vi zu ein
Fashion Show werde ich jetzt bei dem
bestimmt nicht mehr eingeladen schade
schade na was haben wir hier einzige was
ich bei denen mag ist wirklich das Logo
ich finde das Logo sieht cool aus oha oh
dieses Rot sieht crazy aus mal kurz mein
alten lippensz abmachen das sieht auch
aus als ob das Plastik wäre gar nicht
echt wäre so perfekt da ist kein
einziger Fussel drin
nichts der ist nicht so stark
pigmentiert und der riecht auch besser
der
riecht der hat so ein ganz eigenen Duft
checke ich aber nicht aber also ist
schön aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so
dass ich sage wow das hat mein das
verändert mein Leben das ist einfach
wahrscheinlich wieder für reiche
Menschen die auch Lippen brauchen aber
natürlich kein Lippenstift für 10 €
kaufen können ohin Gott aber es ist echt
eine schöne Farbe Nummer 5 ist ein
großes Paket mit einem normalen Inhalt
mit Make-up bewerfen Sie ein hier noch
ein Lipstick Slam velvet radical da
nehme ich alles zurück der wirkt
hochwertig der wirkt Luxus teuer
wirklich mega Farbe und guckt mal wieder
aus ne wir machen den nicht rund wir
machen den eckig und das ist eine
Fullsize na na doch wahrscheinlich schon
oh der sieht cool ne benutzen wir mal
noch nie in meinem Leben
eckigen
gesehen es ist bisschen schwer in
aufzutragen wunderschön okay nach diesen
Kalendern muss ich jetzt eigentlich
jeden Tag roten Lippenstift tragen ich
habe jetzt so viele roten Lippenstift
der ist wunderschön ich kann nicht
anderes sagen der sitzt auch richtig gut
drauf
und nice und der ist auch nicht so
perfüiert ich weiß nicht was mit diesem
ersten Lippenstift war Türchen num es
ist
Nikolaus ja ist das eine make-upmel nein
es ist ein Modehaus bei Dior hat echt
schon viel Parfüm
reingeknallt oh es ist ein Parfüm
endlich mal mit so einem Applikator bei
diesen ganzen Proben auch bei Dior haben
sie immer nur diese offenen Flaschen die
man dann irgendwie sich drauf bappen
muss sa Laurent das ist die colab mit
dem y
Kollektiv ich habe das Gefühl mit diesen
kalendervos werde ich hier langsam zum
perfümexperten also es ist auf jeden
Fall eine Menge die man hier bekommt das
riecht richtig gut frisch
edel das ist ein Parfüm den das würde
ich zum Dinner anziehen Nummer 7 was hat
die Luxuswelt zu bieten skincare ein
night Reboot Serum ein Serum was ihr in
der Nacht auftragen sollt also ihr nicht
ich eigentlich auch nicht aber rich
people das hat hier auch so zwei
Schichten und dann mischt man es und
macht sich das ist ja krass Leute ich
sag's wie es ist ich packe euch das in
die verlosungsbox ich habe so viele
Seren mit diesen Kalendern jetzt
bekommen das geht an euch in Nummer 8
bekommen wir etwas in schwarz eingepackt
von der Vielfalt gesehen ist so ein
Kalender schon sehr limitiert ne jetzt
wollen Sie wirklich zeigen dass sie
skincare haben noch ein pure shot Hydra
bounce Lotion essence UPS Arschloch
Leute das gebe ich euch ganz genauso wie
das nightserum da könnt ihr euch auf
mich verlassen Türchen Nummer ne oh mein
Gott ich
habe Leute falls ihr dachtet dass dieses
Video gesponsert ist dann liegt ihr
komplett richtig eV sa Laur hat mich
dafür bezahlt dass ich den
Adventskalender auspacke denn sie haben
mein Potenzial gesehen sie haben gesehen
das Mädchen das ist ein luxusgir und
dieses Luxus girlir weiß was gut ist
teste bitte unseren Kalender nein Spaß
dieses Video ist nicht gesponser und
jetzt alle dieses Video ist nicht
gesponser aber also wenn ihr mich mal
auf so eine Fashion Week nach Paris oder
so einladen wollt ich mache euch dann
auch Interviews mit der VOG ist kein
Problem
ernsthaft und jetzt kommen wir zu
Türchen Nummer 9 und türche Nummer 9 ist
das beste Türchen denn ist meine
Lieblingszahl und ich gehe davon aus
deswegen auch was Gutes drin ist es ist
schon wieder ein Lippenstift R
provocation also wenn jetzt noch ein
dritter roter Ton ist ja das ist war
wirklich so eine Probe weil das fühlt
sich richtig billig an der fühlt sich
hochwertig an nach Luxus und der hat
doch fast die gleiche Farbe wie der
erste na absolut nicht das sind komplett
verschiedene Rottöne das sehen wir ganz
klar ich sag euch aber ganz ehrlich
dieser Rotton steht mir bestimmt
fantastisch aber ich habe aus dem Dior
Adventskalendern ein Rotton und ich
finde es ist an der Zeit dass ich euch
mal ein richtig tollen Lippenstift in
die verlosungsbox reinpacke ne deswegen
ich werde den jetzt nicht probieren ich
habe ein tolles rotgad auf den Lippen
ich bin überrascht darüber wie viele
rote Lippenstifte sie auf Lager haben
aber gut welche Farbe soll sonst ein
Lippenstift haben ne that's true ja true
Nummer ze das wird hier schon wieder
irgende essence sein diese Flaschen die
damit tun Sie sich echt kein Gefallen
Make-up Remover komm also das hätte ein
bisschen größer doch ausfallen können
das ist ja wirklich so eine einmalprobe
jetzt mal ganz ehrlich wer würde sich
ein Make-up remov von der Marke wie eV
holen da gibt's ja hunderte günstigere
Marken also so ein Lippenstift kann ich
mir vorchellen meiner Tante z.B habe ich
vor zwei Jahren ein Lippenstift von Dior
zu Weihnachten geschenkt weil ich finde
das ist einfach ein schönes ein sehr
toller hochwertiger Lippenstift so und
Dior macht dann auch einfach was her
aber Make-up Remover Nummer 11 das ist
doch schon schon wieder was ist das Oil
instick ist das schon wieder ein
Lippenstift aber jetzt ist es was mit Öl
es ist ein lippensft oh mein Gott ist
hier der auch vom Metall und sowas der
fühlt sich an wie Lippenstifte aus den
50ern wo die noch so produziert wurden
dass man einfach nur Nachfüller geholt
hat für sein extrem tolles ETI für das
Lippen Zeug uh Glitzer ja den muss ich
benutzen der also der der gefällt mir
optisch so gut der wird getestet und der
hat so Glitzer oder so ist ganz
crazy oh mein
Gott what das fühlt sich wirklich ölig
auf den Lippen an das sieht gar nicht so
krass glänzend aus wie sich das anfühlt
beim Auftragen fühlt es sich an als ob
man mit einem Stück Butter über die
Lippen fährt und das so auf den Lippen
schmilzt der fühlt sich auch so richtig
easy to use an und der sieht wunderschön
aus und hat ein tolles also das ist
Weihnachtsgeschenk dies J an mich selbst
dafür muss man nur 345 € für
Adventskalender ausgeben was kostet den
dieser Lippenstift 40
€ der ist aber gut bewertet hält lange
und verschmiert nicht außerdem eine
traumhafte Farbe super teuer aber eine
coole Kombination von Lipgloss und
lipball das Design ist toll sehr schöner
Lippenstift ja ich muss auch sagen ich
bin
Fan
Halbzeit mit diesen Proben machen sie
sich irgendwie keinen gefallen weil die
wirken einfach ein bisschen billig
Mascara ich habe zwar schon genug
Mascara aber das lasse ich mir nicht
nehmen wow extrem guter Mascara wow er
macht die Wimpern genauso wie ich sie
haben möchte man kann auch öfter rüber
gehen und es verklumpt kein bisschen in
Nummer 13
taxido haben wir hier etwa ein Duft für
Timo das riecht nach dem Schnaps sorry
das riecht das riecht einfach nur nach
dem Schnaps Schnaps der neue Duft von
is okay ich muss mich beeilen ich habe
Timo versprochen dass wir Mittagessen
gehen und ich brauche hier schon wieder
ein bisschen zu lange Nummer 14 das wird
doch schon wieder ein Lippenstift das
ist ein Lippenstift Adventskalender das
ist ein Lippenstift Adventskalender aber
cool wenn
man diese Farbe oh das ist ja ein
wunderschönes rot aber ich hab doch
jetzt schon so viel Rot
aber ich verlos das an euch ich brauche
nicht so viele rote Lippenstifte ich
möchte am liebsten alle einmal auftragen
aber ich brauche nicht so viele ich muss
das akzeptieren deswegen der geht an
euch Bo ich gebe euch dieses Mal richtig
viele
generös 15 ich frage mich was für eine
Lippenstiftfarbe hier drin sein
wird lash Clash noch eine Mascara also
mit dieser Einsortierung ich weiß nicht
wenn man ein Adventskalender plant und
dann guckt man okay wo packen wir die
Sachen rein man sollte doch versuchen es
so reinzulegen dass es immer abwechselnd
ist und die machen dann so hier zwei
Pflegeprodukte 16 Lippenstifte drei
Mascara ich sag euch wie es ist der geht
an euch den F nicht an 16 ist doch schon
wieder ein
Lippenstift
l ich Französisch wunderbar
Mist den finde ich besser oh der riecht
ja toll tolle Flaschen hatten wir bei
Dior z.B nicht dass man mal ordentlich
sprühen kann und das parfü auch richtig
benutzen kann 17 ich bin mal gespannt ob
wir noch hier überrascht werden la Creme
essentiell Rouge sieht ein bisschen nach
Rituals aus ja krass gar nicht so doll
perfüiert wie ich jetzt erwartet hätte
bei der Marke geht an euch schm mir
jetzt hier keine Creme drauf 18 hier
sehe ich doch schon
wieder was war das mit meiner
Stimme
oh ist die auch toll ja jetzt ist es
wichtig wie ich als Kind erzogen wurde
mir so viel mir mit dir gegeben ja ma
zuande möchte ich den mit meiner
Community teilen oder behalte ich ihn
selber weil er mir so gut gefällt ich
habe ja schon ein in einer bräunlicheren
Farbe und hier ist ein bisschen mehr ein
warmes rötliches Ding drin ich gebe ihn
euch ich packe ihn in die Verlosung ich
brauche nicht so viele Nummer 19 ja ihr
seid halt alles meine Freunde und ich
muss mit euch
teilen P Shots also diese Pflegereihe
von der Wirkung auch und so das fühlt
sich wirklich an wie so Füller für
diesen Adventskalender ja das gibt's
natürlich für euch soft Polish ich weiß
nicht mal was ein Soft Polish sein soll
hier ist auch so wenig Erklärung drin
und so das muss man sich ein bisschen
ergoogeln es ist so eine kleine
Plastikflasche das wirkt also neben
diesem Teil wirkt das halt wirklich wie
so ja wir haben hier noch
makeup remover 20 mon Paris wie riecht
den mon paris mon Paris sieht aus wie
ein Diamant montpis riecht nach
moncherie und jetzt nicht mal als Witz
es riecht wie eine alkoholische Kirsche
monerie mit der pamontkirsche wer kann
dazu schon nein sagen mag ich nicht wen
bekommt ihr da fällt mir nicht so schwer
bei solchen Sachen kann ich euch ganz
einfach sagen bekommt ihr pack ich in
die Verlosung bei anderen Sachen ist es
ein bisschen schwieriger aber am Ende
bin ich auch einfach nur Mensch
21 unser Kalender kann jetzt in den USA
Alkohol trinken in der 21 gibt's von der
gleichen Pflegeserie noch den Augen
Reboot mit Koffein für die Augen klar 22
das fühlt sich so komisch an und es hat
ein ganz anderes Packpapier
warum warum guck mal da seid Ihr der
sieht cool aus so warum sollte ich so
ein Spiegel haben wollen das ist einfach
nur ein kleiner Spiegel also den kann
ich mir nirgendswo hinstellen so ja wenn
ich mit meinem Make-up unterwegs bin
dann ja ist ist ein Spiegel vorlztes
Türchen Nummer 23 noch ein Perfum libre
sieht ja Chicky aus eingelegte Gurken
Spaß na die geben mir nicht so viel die
Parfüme aber ich bin auch nicht so ein
parfümtyp ich glaube auch Parfüm in so
Flaschen riecht einfach nach Alkohol ich
glaube man muss es schon verteilen um
diesen Duft zu versprühen weil die haben
mir z.B auch besser gefallen und die
konnte ich versprühen und muss nicht so
direkt an der Flüssigkeit riechen
wahrscheinlich gefallen mir deswegen die
ganzen perfüme nicht
so Christmas in my
heart langsam darf ich wirklich in
Weihnachtsstimmung sein wir haben mit
diesen Adventskalendern im September
angefangen und jetzt kann man Lebkuchen
essen ohne schlechtes Gewissen wir gehen
an Weihnachten an unseren
Adventskalender bekommen Lippenstift ja
gut was sollte hier als Highlight drin
sein ne muss man ehrlich sagen ich
glaube guckt mal da bekommt ihr noch
einen diese Farbe hatten wir doch in
irgendeinem jetzt noch mal so drin wir
vergessen den erster Linie dass er 345 €
gekostet hat weil das ist ein
make-upkender von einer make-upmarke für
Menschen in einer ganz anderen
Preiskategorie die Leute kaufen sich
auch ganz casual ein Gucci T-Shirt oder
was weiß ich ein Kleid für 1500 €. das
sind auch die Menschen die können ins
Grill Royale gehen die gucken nicht auf
die Preise die bestellen das worauf sie
Lust haben muss mich jetzt ganz kurz
reinversetzen also Geld ist mir egal ich
habe jetzt diesen Kalender gekauft weil
ich die Marke mag es ist schon einfach
sehr viel Lippenstift ich find es mega
lustig fürs Video wenn sowas passiert
finde ich es einfach nur funny aber wenn
ich den jetzt Privat gekauft hätte was
will ich mit so viel Lippenstift da
stellt sich mir die Frage haben sie auch
noch so andere Produkte also die haben
Foundation Concealer und Perfum nee
eyeshadow palette Mini ein einzelner
Lidschatten ist hier auch zu sehen ein
Cultur Highlighter der kostet halt auch
49 € dieser Lippenstift war zweimal drin
und der kostet 40 € ich sag euch mal was
eins ne hört mir ganz genau zu ich weiß
ihr findet meine Meinung extrem wichtig
macht diesen Kalender zu einem Z Türen
Adventskalender macht die noch ein ganz
bisschen günstiger dadurch dass ihr nur
zw Türchen habt und dann macht ihr so
drei Parfüme rein drei Lippenstifte
Lidschatten und Mascara und dann ist
jeder happy ich glaube diese
Pflegeprodukte von denen also Serum und
creme und so das braucht man gar nicht
weil das ist eh viel zu wenig die Haut
sich nach zwei Wochen daran gewöhnt hat
ist es auch Quatsch Z Türchen schöne
Produkte drin nicht zu viele
Wiederholungen von etwas perfekt und
vielleicht dadurch ein bisschen
günstiger 12 days of Christmas ich finde
hier ein paar Produkte wirklich sehr gut
aber wie viele Lippenstifte hatten wir
jetzt acht rote Lippenstifte in
verschiedenen Farbtönen brauch kein
Mensch außer du bist nee nicht mal
Marilyn Monroe die hatte ja immer nur
ein rot getragen ansonsten ist dieses
Video ja einfach schnutzpie egal ich
hoffe ihr hatte trotzdem Spaß beim
zuschauen und freut euch mit mir auf die
große Verlosung denkt dran auf Instagram
und wenn ihr mir fallen tun wollt dann
abonniert mich doch gerne ich habe
gesehen dass
57% der Leute die meine Videos schauen
mich gar nicht abonnieren und da wollte
ich fragen hey lass doch mal ein Abo da
und wenn ich dann die Millionen geknackt
habe und meinen coolen goldenen play
bututton mal endlich kriege dann könnt
ihr mich auch wieder gerne entabonnieren
das da bin ich euch gar nicht böse ich
will ja also guckt meine Videos das ist
schon schön aber ich will dieses goldene
Ding haben bitte ich mache das ganze
jetzt hier seit 8 ne Jahren einmal so
ein ne ich Stö euch jetzt nicht weiter
ne bis dann ich muss jetzt mal was essen
tschüss Leute